-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Thanks for being here.
Thanks for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone
was talking about this.
Last night, at the end
of a White House photo op,
journalists weren't supposed to
ask any questions.
But Fox News reporter
Peter Doocy
asked President Biden
whether inflation
would hurt him in the midterms,
and a hot mic picked up
Biden's response.
Watch this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When your age is almost 80
and your approval rating's
almost 30,
you can pretty much say
whatever you want, I think.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, listen, if Biden's
next three years
are going to be grandpa
at Thanksgiving, sign me up.
I'm in, I'm in.
You could tell that felt good
for Biden,
because today he was
fielding questions like,
"Yeah, the moron in the back."
[ Laughter ]
"How about Dopey in the corner,
you got something to say?"
Thankfully there were
no hard feelings,
and Biden even called Doocy
to clear the air.
Listen to this.
-That led to a phone call
from the president
within about an hour
of the salty exchange,
Biden telling Doocy, quote,
"It's nothing personal, pal."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Then Biden said,
"I'll say it again real slow
so you can understand.
It's nothing personal, pal."
Not sure that excuse
really flies.
It's sort of up there with,
"Don't take this the wrong way."
"Don't take this the wrong way,
but you look tired."
I hate when people tell me
I look tired.
Can we just take that
out of our vernacular?
-Yes.
-Why would you say that?
-Well, also --
-"Hey, you look bad."
-[ Laughs ]
It's like, "Thank you.
Yeah, but actually,
I'm not tired.
I slept great last night.
This is how I look not tired."
Of course, all the networks
were reporting on the exchange.
But I saw that
the far-right network OAN
accidentally added insult
to injury for Peter Doocy.
Take a look.
-President Biden,
the United States president,
calls for Fox News White House
correspondent Peter Douchey.
He called him, quote,
"a stupid son of a [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
-Peter Douchey.
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Peter Douchey.
Biden was like, "Thanks, I'll
have to use that one tomorrow.
I appreciate it."
That was like,
"Peter Douchey -- I'm sorry.
[ Clears throat ]
Penis Douchey.
I'm s-- I'm sorry.
I can't read this.
Peter Doocy."
Peter Doocy actually
heard that anchor
and was like,
"You stupid some of a --"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Biden is already
dealing with enough
as tensions continue to rise
over a Russian invasion
of Ukraine.
The Department of
Homeland Security has warned
that Russia could launch
a cyberattack against the U.S.
Yeah, they're basing this
on evidence
from every day
for the last 60 years.
[ Laughter ]
But the attacks
could be serious.
Russia could cripple
the electrical grid
or, worse, turn off TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
Americans are like,
"Just in case,
I'm changing my password
from '1234' to '1234!'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's right.
Yeah, an attack
on our electrical grid
would ground commercial flights.
So at United, it'll be
pretty much business as usual.
[ Laughter ]
And, of course,
former President Trump
decided to weigh in on
the Ukraine/Russia crisis.
In a statement, he said
this never would have happened
under his administration.
Yeah, 'cause he would have
just called Putin like,
"Just take it."
[ Laughter ]
"What the hell do I care?
Just take it."
-"Sir."
-Yeah, "Sir."
Trump didn't stop there.
He also claimed that under
his administration,
the green M&M
would still be sexy.
[ Laughter ]
Let's change gears.
I read that the SAT exam
is going fully digital
and being shortened
from three hours to two.
Wow, that's like --
that's like --
Sorry, I don't have an analogy.
I bombed on the verbal
on my SATs.
I'm more of a math guy.
[ Laughter ]
Who cares?
I signed my name.
I got 200 points.
Eventually the exam
will just be one question --
"Do you have $200,000
to pay for college?"
[ Laughter ]
"No."
"Perfect, come on in."
[ Applause ]
Some business news.
Twitter is reportedly working
on a "close friends" feature
that would let users share
tweets with up to 150 people.
That story again --
Twitter is inventing
the group chat from hell.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a puffer fish named Goldie
had to undergo
emergency dental work
because her teeth were too big.
Here she is before and after.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
The hardest part was putting on
the lead vest for the X-ray.
When the dentist said, "You may
experience some swelling,"
the puffer fish was like,
"Don't take this the wrong way,
but I'm a puffer fish.
I'm used to it,
you stupid son of a --"
There you go.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody.